Dùng lúc làm sập máy vòng trở, tốt máy nhiều nhà ở cần thơ.
Thôi mùa tốt hất chết xây dời,
sẽ không được bắt,
để đi nhà là tốt rồi lột.
Nó như lúc,
mình sẽ muốn máy người ta luôn.
Sáng 12 tháng 20,
dùng lúc quét qua sả trụ hương,
khiến máy vòng nhà lồng trở lấp vòng sập,
máy tồn bị hết vòng.
Bột số nhà dân tốt máy,
chú điện bị quật nha.
Chú điện này là máy vậy,
bắt nha là.
Chánh ký trở,
sắp hoàn nhẹ,
nãy nhỏ hẳng kế là dòng rồi em,
Vì tính thảo hình dở hình,
mùa chó hiệp,
vấn lúc dòng mà,
hình dạ dương trở,
mình ngàn cũng mẹ tạm,
mình dạ dịch tưởng thằng thằng thằng chăm mất.
Quảng sống bị chính xí,
đã mộ được huy động để thiệt chường,
giòn dẹp của chợ người dân khát phục hợp qua,
chính quyền đàn túng kê thiệt hại.